et dans notre chronique santé
aujourd'hui les allergies alimentaires
et autres intolérance qui sont en hausse
selon un rapport de la cdc le centre de
surveillance des maladies aux états unis
alors comment expliquer ce phénomène qui
est en réalité une réaction du système
immunitaire comment les parents
doivent-ils s'organiser au quotidien on
en parle avec julia stieger bonjour
julien bonjour à tout d'abord qu'est-ce
qui provoque ces allergies alimentaires
alors déjà une allergie alimentaire
c'est en fait une réaction du système
immunitaire une réaction qui est
peut-être considérée comme anormale en
fait quand votre corps est en contact
avec un pathogène avec un virus il va
vous le savez maintenant mais il va
créer des anticorps pour se protéger
bien c'est la même chose pour une
personne qui est allergique à un aliment
quand le corps détecte cet aliment il va
le détecté comme étant justement un
agresseur il va avoir on va il va créer
en fait une réaction de type i ge donc
des immeubles des immunoglobulines et en
fait on n'est jamais allergiques un
aliment en tant que tel mais plutôt à
une protéine spécifique qui est contenu
dans cet aliment alors si cette attaque
justement du système immunitaire qui va
créer des effets sur le corps ça peut
être des démangeaisons des rougeurs ça
peut être aussi des picotements souvent
au niveau de la bouche une production de
mucus enfin il ya beaucoup de
différences symptômes et en général
alors ça peut se produire juste après
l'ingestion de l'aliment mais souvent ça
se passe plutôt en deux étapes c'est à
dire que la première fois que vous êtes
exposés à cet aliment votre système
immunitaire bah en fait se sensibiliser
et la deuxième fois c'est là que vous
allez voir les effets indésirables alors
souvent les symptômes sont légers mais
dans certains cas eh bien ça peut être
très grave voire même mortels c'est le
fameux choc anaphylactique dont vous
avez entendu parler évidemment alors
quelle est la différence entre une
allergie et une intolérance alimentaire
on entend beaucoup parler de ces
intolérances alimentaires et bien tout
simplement les allergies en effet il va
y avoir une réaction du système
immunitaire et elles peuvent être
mortels ce qui n'est pas le cas avec les
intolérances alimentaires mais dans les
deux cas il faudra apprendre à éviter
l'essai aliments là alors qu'en tête que
les allergies alimentaires apparaissent
et comment les détecter alors
habituellement ça apparaît avant l'âge
de quatre ans pourquoi parce que le
système digestif et le système
immunitaire est encore pas très mature
et donc ils sont plus susceptibles aux
allergies alors il ya des signes avant
coureurs surtout chez les plus petits ça
peut être par exemple des problème orl
des otites à répétition des problèmes de
sommeil ça peut être aussi des problèmes
de constipation ou de diarrhées des
problèmes de peau comme par exemple de
l'eczéma ça peut être aussi une cassure
dans la courbe de croissance ou de
poitou ceux ci sont des signes qui
doivent alerter alors il y as pour
confirmer le diagnostic différents types
de tests qui existe des tests sur la
peau que l'on connaît tous des tests
sanguins mais aussi des tests que l'on
appelle de provocation c'est à dire
qu'en fait on va vous donner de petites
quantité d'allergène tous les jours ça
se fait dans un hôpital avec un
allergologue et l'idée c'est en fait
d'essayer de recréer de la tolérance à
cet allergène alors la plupart du temps
par contre il n'existe pas vraiment de
traitement curatif et on conseille
d'essayer de bannières de la
consommation ces produits allergènes la
bonne nouvelle c'est que vous avez
certain type d'allergie qui vont avoir
tendance à s'atténuer voire même à
disparaître c'est le cas par exemple des
des allergies au lait de vache aux oeufs
ou au soja par contre vous avez d'autres
types d'allergies comme par exemple les
arachides les noix ou encore le poisson
les fruits de mer qui ont tendance à
persister tout au long de la vie quels
sont les principaux aliments allergènes
alors ce qui est intéressant ici c'est
que ça dépend en fait des pays est en
fait tous et ça c'est en fonction du
type d'alimentation ou au japon par
exemple c'est l'allergie au riz qui va
prédominer alors que dans les pays
scandinaves et bien ce sera les
allergies aux poissons alors dans les
pays occidentaux ce sont les aliments
suivants qui sont responsables d'environ
90% des allergies alimentaires il ya
environ huit familles que vous voyez ici
que vous reconnaissez évidemment on
entend parler les arachides les fruits
les noix le lait de vache les oeufs le
poisson donc voilà il ya environ huit
familles comme ça qui sont responsables
de 90% des allergies alimentaires
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya une
augmentation du nombre de personnes
atteintes d'allergies alors oui
effectivement selon le dédain un rapport
de l'acide ici aux etats unis il y à une
augmentation la prévalence des allergies
alimentaires a augmenté de 18 % chez les
moins de 18 ans entre 1997 et 2007 est
alors de nos jours on dit qu'il ya
environ 10% des enfants qui ont une
allergie alimentaire environ 8% et des
adultes on a demandé justement à
angélina galinier varin qui est
journaliste santé qui a créé un blog
aussi qui s'appelle ma femme lit life
pour essayer de guider et d'accompagner
les parents d'enfants poli allergiques
on lui a demandé pourquoi justement
comment expliquer cette hausse des
allergies alimentaires ont les côtes
je pense que le contexte actuel
envers les conditions environnementales
la transformation aujourd'hui des
aliments que l'on trouve dans le
commerce sont que les aliments sont de
plus en plus transformé qu'on retrouve
de plus en plus de deux suppléments dans
les ingrédients et enfin dans les
préparations et les enfants
aujourd'hui
surtout quand ils sont un petit ange
typiquement quand on prend un petit pot
de légumes aujourd'hui ils ont tous de
la pomme de terre où tous de la pomme ça
veut dire que compliqué de trouver
aujourd'hui des aliments qui sont pures
et nature et tout cela contribue à
l'augmentation des allergènes
alors il y a les produits transformés
qui sont une cause on entend aussi les
scientifiques expliqué que ce serait
peut-être aussi le fait que l'on vit
dans un environnement qui est de plus en
plus est aseptisé et donc on deviendrait
de plus en plus fragiles alors vous
trouverez sur internet sur ce blog comme
sur d'autres beaucoup d'informations sur
comment justement contourner les
produits allergènes comment réorganiser
son quotidien comment gérer la
collectivité comment faire ses courses
dans les supermarchés parce que vous
imaginez bien h rennes que quand le
diagnostic tombait bien c'est toute une
réorganisation du foyer qui doit
s'opérer et rapidement est-ce qu'on peut
prévenir ces allergies alimentaires
alors il est des pistes de prévention
tous les scientifiques ne s'accorde pas
là dessus mais on entend souvent dire
que il faut déjà éviter le tabagisme
c'est très important sur les enfants en
bas âge et sur les ados aussi insisté
sur les bienfaits de la de l'allaitement
maternel exclusif jusqu'à quatre à six
mois et enfin essayé de vraiment
respectée l'introduction des aliments
solides selon un calendrier qui a été
élaboré par les pédiatres merci beaucoup
julien pour cette chronique santé c